So when it comes to putting
ads in a native app,
there's actually a lot of different
things we have to consider.
Especially because the screen
size on a phone or
a tablet is a lot smaller than it
might be on a desktop application.
So what do we have to keep in mind?
>> There are several things.
Every app offer a different type
of experience to its users.
So it's important that your ad
format match that experience.
While a banner ad may work well for
a flashlight app, a gaming app could
benefit much more from a full video app.
In other words,
you need to take into consideration
the placement within your app and
the different ad formats.
You could try the two leading platforms.
Adsense or double-click.
However, there are other platforms
out there for you to check out.
>> And we've linked them in
the instructor notes below.